-Hi, my friend!
-Hello, friend.
-I am so --
We were talking backstage.
The first two episodes
of "Barry" that I watched --
it's just fantastic.
-Oh, thank you.
-You play a hitman.
-Uh-huh.
-Who wants to become an actor.
-How --
[ Light laughter ]
How did you come up
with that idea?
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-No, it was this thing
where Alec Berg,
who I co-created the show
with...
-He's a fantastic writer.
-He does "Silicon Valley"
and -- and a lot of things.
We just thought --
You know, I said,
"What if I played a hitman?"
And he went,
"Oh, I hate the word --
just 'hitman,'
just what it conjures up,
like cool guy
and two guns and everything."
I was like,
"No, but it will be me."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And he started laughing.
-Uh-huh.
-And he went, "No, serious."
And I was like,
"No, me as a hitman.
And what if he was a former
Marine?" -- whatever.
And then, very quickly, somehow,
we just thought, "Oh,
he should take an acting class."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know.
And then --
And then we went in to HBO
and said,
"Yeah, I'm a hitman
who takes an acting class."
And they -- they just went, "Um,
all right, yeah, sure, sure."
[ Laughter ]
-You directed the first three?
-That's right, yeah.
-Was that something that
you knew
as soon as you were doing a show
that you wanted to direct
some of them?
-Yeah, yeah,
I really wanted to direct.
That's kind of what
I wanted to do before, you know,
I was even doing comedy
or any of that.
And it was interesting
doing this and directing myself,
but, also, the other actors.
They wouldn't know --
like, Sarah Goldberg,
who was in that scene --
she's great in the show --
but she said she wouldn't know
if I was reacting in character
or if I was reacting
as the director.
-[ Chuckling ] Right.
-'Cause she would be --
so, we'd be doing a scene
and I'd be going...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
And she's like,
"Is that -- Is that --
That's --
That's the character, right?
That's not you?"
And I'm like, "No, no, no.
No, no. That's the character."
-Uh-huh.
-Yeah.
And he hates your acting.
No, no.
[ Laughter ]
No, she -- No, she --
she's phenomenal on the show.
-You --
You have a fantastic cast --
Stephen Root,
who's a great actor.
The acting teacher
is Henry Winkler.
-Yes, Henry Winkler is in it.
Yes.
-Who is one of those people --
and I'm sure
you'll attest this, as well --
he came on this show --
he's one of those guys --
nothing would be worse
than if he was a bad guy.
-No, yeah, he's the nicest
human being on the planet.
-And you need it to be the case.
You need Henry Winkler
to be as nice as he is.
-Yes. And then we cast him
as a very angry acting coach.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And there is a scene
in the pilot
where he has to make
Sarah Goldberg cry.
And he's yelling at her
and everything.
And I went over. I go, "Henry,
you got to really go at her.
Like,
don't worry about the words --
you just got to, you know,
try to make her cry."
And he pulled me aside.
He goes, "Bill,
I need to understand something.
This man I'm playing --
he's an [bleep]"
[ Light laughter ]
I said, "Yes, he's an [bleep]"
He went, "Okay."
[ Light laughter ]
And then, he did this take,
and he went at her so hard.
And you were just --
We're like, "Whoa!"
[ Laughter ]
And she was going, "Oh, God."
It's in the show.
She's like, "Wait, whoa,
Henry, what's going on?"
He was just, like...
[ Shouting gibberish ]
It was like, "Oh, Henry."
So, deep down,
he's, like, a -- a maniac.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Good to find out, and now --
-He's a monster. No.
-And what
I'm so excited about is --
tonally, it's unlike anything,
not only have I --
that I've seen from you,
but I feel like very --
it's really funny, very dark.
-Yeah.
-Has some great action elements.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And -- And did that
just kind of come in the process
of -- of sitting down?
Or when you were like,
"I'm gonna do a show for HBO --
I want there to be a lot
of action, as well"?
-Yeah.
It's like if the guy from --
you know, if -- if "Unforgiven,"
like, William Munny
in "Unforgiven"
or the guy from "Taxi Driver"
met the people from
"Waiting for Guffman."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
And they were like,
"How much money do you need?"
-Yeah, they're like, "Boy,
that's the idea of the century!"
[ Laughter ]
"We love it!"
-You just -- you did a premiere
at South by Southwest in Austin.
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
-I've heard you saying
it's fun to go to
different parts of the country,
because of the way
people say "Barry."
-Yeah, yeah.
In Austin, it was like,
"So, man, you're with the show
'Barreh.'"
[ Light laughter ]
And I was like, "Excuse me?"
And they're like,
"Barreh! Barreh! Would you --"
Yeah, and then -- and here, I
come to New York, and it's like,
[New York accent]
"So, Bill Hader
with the show 'Barry'!"
[ Laughter ]
"It's 'Barry,' everybody.
Here he comes --
Barry, everybody.
Come in here."
And I'm like, "Oh, my God."
-"Barry" different places.